"Tilt", a new feature at 360 CHICAGO, the observation deck at John Hancock Center,...
...allows participants a more immersive viewing experience...
...than just looking out a wall of windows.
The attraction tilts downward 30 degrees,...
...giving sightseers a fresh perspective on what lies below.
From 1,000 feet in the air, viewers are treated to unique vistas of Lake Michigan,...
...the Magnificent Mile and the city's skyline,...
...that is, if they can stomach the movement and overcome their vertigo.
"Tilt" consists of a tipping platform, eight windows, bars to hold on to and a lot of steel.
In total, the metal box weighs 31,000 pounds.
Adventurers take their place, hold on...
...and watch as the logic-defying angle adjustment begins.
All the while, the hydraulic system and the three pistons it powers...
...emit a bit of an industrial roar.
One of the first to try the feature out was Kevin Tibbles, a correspondent for NBC.
The experience prompted him to tweet,...
"Yikes, a thousand feet up and the window's moving!"